pop
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
danse de retour d'algérie s'est accrue
cette semaine en même temps que le
paquebot el djazaïr tout et portant
accosté le quesnoy en porteur d'un
nouveau milliers de radios
c'est presque 8000 retours quotidiens a
annoncé deux secrétaires d'état ont
rapatrié monsieur poulat que nous des
cantons maintenant famille et enfin
forment la majorité de ces retours qui
en général après un passage au centre
d'accueil se disperse pour retrouver un
toit dans leur famille ou chez des amis
métropolitains en attendant que l'avenir
leur désigne leur chemin établissements
en france nous rentrer en algérie où ils
retrouveront un pays qu'ils aiment ou
ils ont en fait déjà
la proche du référendum
d'autodétermination en dépit des
nouveaux drames déchaînée par loi s
après huit jours de trêve à déterminer
certaines mesures messali hadj leader du
mnr a été rendu à une complète liberté
son parti prendra part à la campagne des
référendums comme le fnm et certains
partis politiques
et dans un discours-programme le général
de gaulle a mis les français en présence
à la fois des faits et de ses grandes
espérances d'un ventre à jour
pour la france le problème algérien
sera résolu au fort
l'algérie disposera des mêmes
l'algérie et la france
pour coopérer organiquement et
régulièrement dès lors
quelle roue
il doit rejouer demain en algérie
les français qui sont établies
qu il aime
qui ont tant fait dijon
et dans ce pays a pas besoin
une fois de plus
j'affirme bon espoir
que ce rôle il le jour entraînements
dès que sera dissipé
les derniers nuages sens bien
par lesquels des fous criminels tentent
encore de les égarer
le général de gaulle ensuite évoqué la
question des institutions dans 9 hrs
accompli et dans l'avenir français ce
qu'il fallait faire
tu fais
mais c'est chacun l'a vu parce que
les institutions nouvelles permettent à
l'état d'agir
au lieu que les anciennes
ne pouvait que l'on a pêché
française princesse
chacun a vu
que la fidl confiance dont vous m'avez
en masse
investi
ma moi même obligé et soutenu
jour après jour
et que cet accord direct entre le peuple
et celui qui a la charge de conduire est
devenu dans les temps modernes est
essentielle à la république
[Musique]
du salon international de l'aviation
légère à cannes présente cette année des
avions pour tous les goûts et pour
toutes les bourses
[Musique]
à l'occasion de ce salon s'est déroulée
une journée militaire de l'aviation est
ici on peut apprécier la maniabilité du
nord 3202 dans un très joli vol de
groupe
[Musique]
l'hélicoptère c'est le saint bernard du
xxème siècle ici une opération de
sauvetage
mais l'hélicoptère c'est aussi la bonne
à tout faire c'est peut-être cela la
dépanneuse de doigts pour les
automobilistes ça évitera en tout cas
les embouteillages
dans ce genre d'opération avec
l'hélicoptère jean en risque d'attraper
le tournis il est plus prudent de se
poser ensuite sur la plate forme d'un
camion pour retrouver ses esprits
l'alouette iii mérite bien son nom elle
évolue tout aussi facilement qu'un petit
oiseau et comme les petits oiseaux
n'aime pas voler seul il organise
d'entre eux un petit balai mais là il
s'agit d'un louette 2
pour les dizaines de milliers de
britanniques qui assistent au derby
d'epsom c'est un jour de fête et comme
on est entre soi on n'hésite pas à
afficher un peu de laisser un vide
le côté col dur c'est pour la tribune
officielle la reine n'est pas là elle
est enrhumé mais la reine mère la
princesse margaret et tonino pas voulu
manquer la
ja 26 chevaux départ 26 chevaux qui vont
offrir le plus extraordinaire spectacle
qu'on ait vu à epsom depuis 180 3 vous
avez bien raison de chercher votre abri
à la jumelle ils ne vont pas rester
longtemps dans le peloton le permis b
psam va battre cette année les records
de chutes du grain ce type de liverpool
et pourtant à epsom il n'y a pas l'ombre
d'un obstacle un faux-pas de romulus
l'un des concurrents et c'est la chute
en cascade bilan sept chevaux les quatre
fers en l'air l'un d'entre eux doit
d'être abattus et si j'obtiens l'hôpital
il est maintenant du sage de rentrer à
l'écurie et pendant ce temps les
rescapés france vers le poteau il en
reste encore suffisamment pour rendre la
tonne pour sa très y en une fin de
course catastrophique pour l'élevage
anglais dans les trois premiers un
cheval irlandais et de chevaux français
et c'est l'irlandais l'aps peur qui
gagne devant hardcore et le cantilien
cette petite promenade de 2400 mètres
rapporte 50 millions aux propriétaires
du fal et 5 millions au jockey
[Musique]
parle de vacances on y arrive dans un
mois nous allons retrouver ce spectacle
insolite d'une ville vidée de ses
habitants quand par un coup de pompe car
chose étonnante du 15 juillet au 1er
septembre tout le monde semble avoir mis
la clé sous la porte c'est le moment où
la plupart des usines se précipite dans
le même soleil et ce congé massif jette
aux mêmes dates sur les gares et sur les
routes des millions d'êtres qui veulent
se croire en vacances
délicieuse vacances de trains bourret et
de routes encombrées mais bien sûr on a
le droit d'aimer ça
[Musique]
l'action va se retrouver en full les
mêmes foules dans les endroits
touristiques
on va jouer les sardines sur les plages
enfin seuls à nous distille les horizons
solitaire la quiétude des petits coins
tranquilles à nous le silence de la mer
à nous aussi le confort du séjour à
l'éloquence de ces signes qui semble
vous dira tout de même si vous étiez
venu plus tôt plus tard en juin ou en
septembre
ah non c'est aussi un sport estival de
coucher à la dure
[Musique]
mais reprendre avec de la com ce mois
d'août comme vous le dit
[Musique]
connais toi toi même recommandé socrates
on peut évidemment là les interroger son
visage dans les glaces du musée grévin
on peut aussi procéder plus
scientifiquement reconstitué par exemple
le visage en n'utilisant que le côté
droit ou en n'utilisant que le côté
gauche
c'est le procédé d amy face qui fait
rage actuellement photographie le cinéma
lui peut réaliser l'opération en direct
si l'on peut dire sans l'aide d'une
paire de ciseaux le système d'optique de
dufour et leclerc en effet placé devant
l'appareil de prise de vue permet à
l'aide d'un miroir réglable d'isoler
chaque côté d'un visage et de montrer
chaque demi visage en un visage complet
ainsi verra-t-on apparaître derrière la
plus tous les jours la personnalité
saturnienne que révèle le côté gauche et
la personnalité et lucienne que cachait
le côté droit du visage bien entendu on
peut aussi faire un seul le audelin avec
le bas de l'autre mais ceci n'est qu'une
fantaisie
contre non plus instructives et fernand
raynaud a bien voulu se prêter à cette
opération à discrète et la découverte
des deux aspects secrets d'un même
visage
les spécialistes sont formels les deux
métamorphoses successives met à nu les
deux personnalités contradictoire que
chacun non cash en lui
on
de raymond devos voici révélé grâce à
l'hémisphère gauche un mois social
disons épanouie
quant à sacha distel lenny face droite
révèle un moins intimes qu'on pourra
juger timide au regard d'un mois sociale
affirmée et il faudra mettre que jean
richard somme toute cache bien son moi
intime
[Musique]
social à vous de jouer maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]